whether or not it's enough to put a
floor under Chinese docks to lift
sentiment to in a Chinese financial
markets and of course regional and world
markets and whether it's enough to rev
up China's economic growth remains to be
seen because under the bonnet China's
economy still going quite slowly we know
that the that the stock market crash is
going to have quite an impact on growth
in the third quarter because financial
market activity will be less our Chinese
investments have taken hits as a result
of volatility but our view has been that
they should let the market find its own
level and now they've done that which is
actually they deserve praise for that so
the market will find its level and
cutting interest rates in order to
stimulate the economy is an appropriate
thing I think it remains a very
treacherous market because investors are
still very much torn between liquidity
which is around the corner and the
prospect of global economic growth which
are still extremely modest China
economic momentum is slowing down make
no mistake the re-engineering of the
economic model the rebalancing of the
economy is obviously creating risk to
reach if you want stall speed so right
now I think if you want to have an
interest in China you need to be very
selective and maybe you can also be a
bit if you want implementing some kind
of arbitrage techniques like being long
certain stocks but also had yourself
against the underlying index exposure
what is actually bad for the majority of
the population we have had in the u.s.
six years of zero interest rate and what
does the economy has to show for very
very little considering all the stimulus
packages to zero interest rate and
support we have a very loops i did
recovery where the high-end sector has
done well and the physical man on the
street hasn't